the Joe Rogan experience do they say
soccer um
were you from like originally in England
yeah no not in England and then it's
football you're only in America they say
soccer but before the like where did it
where did it become football was it
always football in Europe who's always
football well why why when it came over
here did it switch over no idea why
didn't they come up with another name
for football probably ever kick a
football I think I think they were
playing football like the soccer
football and then somebody picked up the
ball and started running with it and
they started tackling each other like I
heard some story like that oh and then
they kind of created football and it
evolved from there but then they never
changed the name is that where they like
footballs called football when the only
person kicks it is a guy who can't even
play the game it's the least significant
person on the team as far as getting
[ __ ] when there's a championship yes
yeah and you're not allowed to hit him
right right and you're not allowed to
hit him yeah that's crazy
you can't hit him it's not while he's in
motion of his vulnerable person they try
to be safe oh so you can't hit him I was
legs up an area oh that's the ball hit
him yet but in the crazy that that's
football it's only one time it gets
kicked right how is that football why
what a silly name right does it make
sense but I'm not mad at it you know
it's like fine that's whatever imagine
if they called you know baseball what
would they call it foul if they called
it foul we're playing foul then
something that happens every now and
then in this game there's nothing to do
it running around the bases is it's it's
about touchdowns you should call it
touchdown yeah touchdown because it's
just yeah baseball it's just like we're
trying to get from base to base yeah
baseball touchdown no they call football
touchdown touchdown the ntl national
touchdown league we're gonna what we're
gonna play touchdown that's the game
football doesn't run through an
explanation of why we call it soccer and
it's
more confusing than we care when you go
back to England if you're from England
and you talking about it to people do
they resent the term soccer like how
does that work some people do like I
used to present the term soccer really
yeah but I live here and as I get over
it you know I'm saying as a person I got
to get over it because it was my
favorite sport growing up yes I just got
over it and then now I even call it
soccer my podcast says soccer I don't
even say football but when I go to
England I just or just when I'm around
football soccer people I say football I
get it yeah it's like if I if I was
talking to someone they wanted to talk
about pool but they want to call it
bumper pool okay the woman's World Cup
they won the World Cup in the United
States did for soccer mm-hmm and but
it's not you know it's football to
people like yourself it's a World Cup
but how can they call the World Cup
soccer to appease the one country that
gives the least amount of [ __ ] about
the sport right no weird yeah that's
that's how over America that's crazy I
really stopped to think about it we made
them change the name of their thing yeah
we're not gonna get in there
well come on soccer okay we're out of it
but we're calling it this they call it
do they call it football in like
Argentina yeah okay everywhere in
football you know but it's football just
their pronunciation and spelling of it
but in Australia they're the rebels are
the rebels oh yeah they have their own
rules they have Australian rules
football yeah they changed the rules
right for more ruggedness yeah cuz
they're - you know what it was over
there they were too used to rugby like
those New Zealand savages - yeah yeah
they're [ __ ] savage you can't play
that bitch-ass game with a helmet these
guys are running around biting each
other in the deck and the scrums
[Applause]